for the last two months the british
people have faced a grave threat
with common sense compassion and
unflinching resolve
we have together observed the toughest
restrictions on our freedoms
in memory changing our way of life on a
scale unimaginable
only months ago all our efforts have
been directed towards protecting
our nhs and saving lives tragically
many families have lost loved ones
before their time
and we share their grief yet our shared
effort has adverted
a still worse catastrophe one that could
have overwhelmed the nhs and claimed
half a million lives
every day dedicated doctors nurses and
social care workers army medics
and more have risked their own lives in
the service
of others and they have helped to cut
the reproduction rate from between 2.6
and 2.8
in april to between 0.5 and 0.9 today
the number of coveted patients in
hospital has fallen by over a third
since easter sunday our armed forces
joined the nhs
to build new hospitals on timetables
that were telescoped from years
to weeks almost doubling the number of
critical care beds
and ensuring that since the end of march
at least a third have
always been available our challenge now
is to find a way forward that preserves
our
hard-won gains while easing the burden
of the lockdown and i will be candid
with the house this is a supremely
difficult balance to strike there could
be no greater mistake
than to jeopardize everything we've
striven to achieve by proceeding too far
and too fast we will be driven not by
hope
or economic revival as an end in itself
but by data and science and public
health
and so the government is today
submitting to the house a plan which is
conditional and dependent as always on
the common sense
and observance of the british people and
on continual
reassessment of the data that picture
varies
across the regions and home nations of
the united kingdom
requiring a flexible response
different parts of the uk may need to
stay in full lockdown longer but any
divergence
should only be short term because as
prime minister of the uk
i am in no doubt that we must defeat
this threat and face the challenge
of recovery together our progress will
depend on meeting five
essential tests protecting the nhs
reducing both the daily death toll and
the infection rate
in a sustained way ensuring that testing
and ppe can meet future demand which is
a
a global problem but one that we must
fix
and avoiding a second peak that would
overwhelm
the nhs a new uk wide joint
biosecurity center will measure our
progress with a five-stage covet
covered alert system and the combined
effect of our measures so far
has been to prevent us from reaching
level five
a situation that would have been in
which the nhs
would have been overwhelmed and to hold
us at
level four thanks to the hard work and
sacrifice of the british people
uh by following the social distancing
rules we're now in a
position where we can move in stages uh
to where i hope the scientific
advice will tell us that we are down to
level
three but this will only happen
if everyone continues to play their part
to stay alert
and to follow the rules we must also
deal with the epidemic in care homes
where a tragic number of the elderly and
vulnerable have been lost
and while the situation is thankfully
improving
there is a vast amount more to be done
and of course we need a
world leading system for testing and
tracking and tracing victims and their
their contact so i'm delighted that
baroness harding
the chair of nhs improvement has agreed
to take charge
of a program that will ultimately enable
us to test
hundreds of thousands of people every
day
all this means that we have begun our
descent
from the peak of the epidemic but our
journey has reached the most
uh perilous moment where a wrong move
could be
disastrous so at this stage
we can go no further than to announce
the first
careful modification of our measures
step one in moving towards
covid alert level three a shift
in emphasis that we can begin this week
anyone who cannot work from home
should be actively encouraged to go to
work and sectors
that are allowed to be open should
indeed
be open but subject subject to social
distancing these include food production
construction manufacturing
logistics distribution scientific
research and
to support this to explain this again
we're publishing guidance for businesses
on how to make these workplaces safe
coved
secure people who are able
to work from home as we've continually
said
should do so people who cannot work from
home
should talk to their employers about
returning
this week and the the difficulties that
they may or may not have
anyone with coveted symptoms obviously
or in a household where someone else has
symptoms should self-isolate
we want everyone traveling to work to be
safe
so people should continue to avoid
public transport
wherever possible because we must
maintain social distancing
which will inevitably limit capacity
instead
people should drive or better still walk
or
or cycle with more activity outside our
homes
we would now advise people to wear a
cloth face covering
in enclosed spaces where social
distancing is not
always possible and you're more likely
to come in contact with people
you don't normally meet the reasons face
coverings
can help to protect each other and
reduce the spread of the disease
particularly if you have coronavirus
like symptoms but this does not mean i'm
going to stress this this does not mean
wearing medical face
2r masks ffp3 which must be reserved
for people who need them we have all
lived so far
with onerous restrictions mr speaker on
outdoor spaces
and exercise and this is
and this is where uh i i i my uh uh on
on right on friendly interjection of
cedar tree because i know he's a keen
swimmer
uh mr speaker and and uh unfortunately
we can't do anything for swimming pools
but we can do something for lakes and
the sea
this is where we can go significantly uh
further
uh and because the there is a lower risk
out from
outdoors than indoles so from wednesday
there will be no limits on the frequency
of
outdoor exercise people can take
you can now walk sit and
rest in parks you can play sports
and exercise and you can do all these
things
with members of your household your own
household
or with one other person
from another household provided you
observe social distancing and remain
two meters apart i do hope that's clear
uh mr speaker and i'm conscious if you
want to come back and
ask questions in more detail i'd be very
happy
uh to answer we shall increase the fines
for the small minority who
uh break the rules starting at 100
pounds but doubling with each
infringement
up to 3600. you can drive as far as you
like
to reach an outdoor space space subject
to the same rules
and the laws and guidance of the
devolved
administrations uh i'm sorry to say
however mr speaker
that we should continue to ask those who
are clinically vulnerable
including pregnant women and people over
70 or those with pre-existing
chronic conditions to take particular
care to minimize contact with those
outside their households and we must
continue to shield people
who are extremely vulnerable they should
i'm afraid remain at home
and avoid any direct contact
with others i know that easing
restrictions for the many will only
increase the anguish of those
who must remain shielded so the
government will look at every possible
way
of supporting the most vulnerable mr
speaker
all of our precautions will count for
little if our country is reinfected from
overseas so i give notice that we shall
introduce
new restrictions at the uk border
requiring 14 days of self-isolation
for international arrivals while
respecting our common travel area
with ireland every day we shall monitor
our progress and if we stay on the
downward
slope and the r remains below one
then and only then will it become safe
to go further and move to the second
step
this will not happen
until the first of june at the earliest
but we may then be in a position to
start the phased reopening of shops to
return children
to early years settings including
nurseries and child minders to return
primary schools to school in stages
giving priority
to the youngest children reception and
years one and year one
and those in year six preparing for
secondary school
and to enable secondary school pupils
facing exams next year
to get at least some time with their
teachers i
our ambition and i stress this is
conditional mr speaker for all primary
school pupils
to return to the classroom for a month
before the summer break to those ends
we are publishing guidance on how
schools might reopen safely step two
could also include allowing cultural
and sporting events behind closed doors
for broadcast which i think would
provide a much needed
boost to national morale but nothing can
substitute mr speaker for human contact
and so the government has asked sage
when and how we could safely allow
people
to expand their household group to
include one other household on a
strictly
reciprocal basis finally miss no no
earlier than july and i must be i'm
conscious that you wanted me to run
to wind up i may say 10 minutes
i understand that perhaps mr speaker
would it be in order if i requested that
my interrogation could continue for a
little bit longer in orbit in order for
me to make all these points
uh no earlier than july we may be able
to move to step three
if and only if supported by the data and
the best
scientific advice we would then open
a rain to aim to reopen aim to reopen
some remaining businesses including
potentially hospitality
cinemas and hairdressers as well as
places of worship
and leisure facilities and this will
depend
on maintaining social distancing and new
ways
of providing services so we will phase
and pilot
any reopenings to ensure
public safety and i must be clear again
if the data goes the wrong
way if the alert level begins to rise we
will have no hesitation
in putting on the brakes delaying or
reintroducing measures
locally regionally or nationally mr
speaker our struggle against this virus
has placed our country under the kind of
strain that will be remembered
for generations but so too has the
response
of the british people so too will
respond to the british people
from dedicated shop workers keeping our
supermarkets open and ingenious teachers
finding new ways of inspiring their
pupils to the kindness of millions
who have checked on their neighbors
delivered food for the elderly or raised
astonishing
amounts for charity in these and in so
many other ways
we are seeing the indomitable spirit of
britain
and mr speaker let me let me summarize
by saying
that people should stay alert by working
from home if you possibly can
by limiting contact with others by
keeping your distance
to two meters apart where possible
washing your hands
where are washing your hands regularly
and if
you or anyone in your household has
symptoms
you all need to safe to self isolate
because if everyone stays alert and
follows the rules we can control the
virus keep the rate
of infection down and keep the number of
infections down
and that is how we will be able mr
speaker to save lives
and to save livelihoods as we begin to
recover from the coronavirus
and i commend this statement to the
house